Well, good morning church.
It's great to be together as it always is.
Great to be together.
If you're new here, my name's John, one of the pastors here.
I get the privilege of preaching most of the time,
but I'm thankful, like last week for Dan filling in to, uh,
continue anchoring us in the truth of God's word.
That's what we do around here,
and we're thankful for that, uh,
including this book called First Samuel
that we're studying through.
And so invite you to take your copy of God's word
and turn there as we're journeying
through in really nearing the end of it.
Now, first Samuel in the Old Testament,
chapter 27 is where we're gonna start today.
Uh, just to catch us up again, reminding us
of what's been happening the last few weeks.
Over the last few weeks, we've seen David
continue growing in his trust of the Lord.
That's the all caps Lord Yahweh,
that Dan talked about last week.
Uh, this is the God almighty kind of Lord who's near,
uh, David's grown in that.
Now, here's the question. Has he figured it out?
Has David finally figured it out?
It seems like he's passed the test that God has put in front
of him, but is he finished
or is there more growth that David needs in his life?
Well, in many ways, the parable of the prodigal son
that Jesus gave in Luke 15 is a close parallel
to the passage we're gonna study today about David.
They will walk in many ways the same path,
and we'll see that today.
And, and we can almost call this the prodigal David story in
a way as we go.
But what it's gonna do is it's gonna show us about David,
of course, but it, it's, it's also gonna challenge us
as we consider the similarities that we'll see in his life
to our life, what that means
as we take our steps forward today.
So I wanna pray briefly to start. God, this is your word.
We trust you with it, and we trust you'll speak
by your Holy Spirit through it.
I can't. You need to, and so open our hearts to see
and understand and apply, not just be hearers of the word
but doers of it because you have loved us.
So thank you, God, help us Holy Spirit, in Jesus' name.
Amen. Now, I had to make a choice
as I was preparing this sermon.
Uh, as you can see, if you've got your notes maybe on the
app, you can see that we're going to actually skip most all
of chapter 28 today.
And, and we're gonna do that next Sunday.
And the reason I did that is
because the chapters we're studying today is, is the story
of David leading up to
and what he was doing during the battle
that we'll see at the end of one Samuel.
This is the David story to get us there, chapter 28.
Most of it is Saul's story of how, how he got there.
And so felt like, you know, it, it's,
it's just like the book has already done over and over.
It's, it's creating tension between Saul and David.
It's, it's a contrast between the two
and how they handled the relationship
with God and relationship with people.
And so this does the narrator inserts 28 in the middle
of David's story to create tension.
But I felt like we just needed
to finish David's story today.
It's gonna help us understand really the fullness of it.
Uh, and then next week we'll get to Saul in chapter 28
and then finish it before we get to Palm Sunday and Easter.
Uh, but I just felt we needed to finish today.
And so we're gonna look at 27 and then 29 and 30 today.
A lot to cover. But uh, just again, think about
what we've seen of David to this point.
And we're gonna put this chart up.
We've put up all of the series so far
and just shows the track of David growing in his trust
of God gaining victory over his enemies,
clearly heading toward the throne.
But Saul, on the other hand,
is heading the exact opposite direction.
And we'll see that end in chapter 31 in a couple weeks.
Today though, today we
take an off ramp and,
and things tend to go awry for David almost outta nowhere.
Like as we take this off ramp, it again parallels
to Luke 15, the parable of the prodigal son.
What we'll see David do today is he runs into the wilderness
and he ran into the wilderness here
in this scene in his life.
And if you saw last week, chapter 26, David trusted God
so well after that chapter 27,
verse one is almost jarring
how quickly this change happens.
Look at verse one, then David said in his heart,
now I shall perish one day by the hand of Saul.
There's nothing better for me than that.
I should escape to the land of the Philistines.
Then Saul will despair
of seeking many longer within the borders of Israel.
I shall escape out of his hand.
Like, what David, do you not remember
what God has done over and over delivered you from this?
And from that, you changed God's changed your heart
to be trusting Saul with God like,
God, you're gonna take care of this.
I know it. I've seen it.
I could have taken his life in chapter 26, but I didn't.
God, you got this. And now this, all
of a sudden he's like, I'm scared of Saul.
I got a leaf. Where did that come from?
Whatever it was that caused David to look again at his
situation, to see what appeared
to be the writing on the wall.
He threw up his hands and ran. He ran, he caved to fear.
Here. He seemed to cave to a fear
that whatever it was caused him to worry
that Saul was gonna find him, was gonna eliminate him,
was gonna keep him from the throne that God had promised.
He caved to that fear
and notice where he went,
like he headed back across the border
to those beloved people,
the Philistines, you remember them, right?
The the ones who presented Goliath as their champion
and David defeated him.
And they're the same ones that David ran away
to earlier in the book
and deceived Aish there and, and all that.
That's the same kind of guys, same people,
but David ran away to them.
Now, it seemed to kinda work, actually, look at verse four.
And when it was told Saul that David had fled to Gath
that's in Philistine country, he no longer sought him.
So it seemed to work. David was like,
I gotta get outta here, so I'm gonna run away to Phil,
to Phil Philistia, and, and God is gonna protect me there.
I I'm not protected here from
Saul, but I'm gonna be protected over there.
It seemed to work. Saul stopped chasing him.
It created a whole new set
of problems that we'll get to in a second.
But it seemed to work. In fact,
David got some nice digs outta the deal.
Watch this, verse five. Then David said to Aish,
if I have found favor in your eyes,
let a place be given me in one of the country towns
that I may dwell there, why should your servant
dwell in the royal city with you?
So that day, Aish gave him, Ziklag gave him the whole town,
and therefore Ziklag belonged to the kings of Judah.
To this day, the number of days
that David lived in the country, the Philistines was a
year and four months.
And so it seemed to work.
He even seemed to have some things going his way.
Yet here's the problem. In his fear,
David was not fully truthful with the Philistines,
just like he'd done earlier.
He ran away to Aish, he acted insane.
They kicked him back out. He was not fully truthful here.
He actually returned to that deception from
before David.
David returned to the deception that he'd done before.
He's doing it again right here
and watch this verses eight through 12.
You'll see it very clearly here as he goes
into this interaction with the Philistines.
Now, David and his men went up
and made raids against the Gsites,
the Gsites, and the Amalekites.
For these were the inhabitants of the land from of old
as far as sure to the land of Egypt.
That's all the enemies of God, basically.
And David would strike the land and would leave neither man
nor woman alive, but would take away the sheep, the ox,
and the donkeys, the camels, the garments,
and come back to Aish.
And when Aish asked, where have you made a raid today,
David would say, against the, the neb of Judah
or against the neb of the lyes
or against the negative of the cites.
And David would leave neither man
nor woman alive to bring news
to Gath thinking lest they should tell about us
and say, so David has done that tattle on him.
Such was his custom. All the while he lived in the country,
the Philistines and Aish trusted David
thinking he has made himself an utter stench
to his people Israel.
Therefore he shall always be my servant.
So lemme explain what's going on here.
David lived far enough away from Aish
that Aish couldn't check on him all the time.
And what he would do is he would lie to Aish about
what he was actually doing
because he was telling Aish that he was going
to attack his own people.
He was gonna, he was going into Israel to fight.
He was going to take his own people's stuff.
But what was he actually doing?
He was weakening the Philistine forces.
He was fighting against those
who were aligning with the Philistines.
He was systematically breaking down their defenses.
Now you might look at that and say, well,
David's just being a, a wise military leader.
He got in behind the, the enemy lines
and he's, he's working from the inside out.
He's, he's a great military leader.
Now that might be partially true,
but we can't discount what verse one said.
Remember, David went to the Philistine country
as a result of his fear.
It wasn't because he was going
with this shrewd military strategy.
He was going because he was afraid it wasn't done out
of trust in the Lord.
In fact, God is not even mentioned in
this whole part right here.
He wasn't asking God anything.
He was just going out of fear.
And so he went, and
what it did is it created a tension here,
attention that David suffered in that he had to deal with.
Now he was, he was in the middle of a mess.
And look down at chapter 28.
Now the first two verses,
we'll see it in those days.
The Philistines gathered their forces for war
to fight against Israel.
This is again, leading to
that last battle we'll get to in a couple weeks.
In chapter 31, they're starting the
preparation for the battle.
And Aish said to David, understand that you
and your men are to go out with me in the army.
You're gonna fight with us.
David said to Aish, very well,
you shall know what your servant can do.
And Aish said to David, very well,
I'll make you my bodyguard for life.
This is the tension. Aish assumed David was on his side.
He, he just knew that that's all he knew was
that David had been fighting his battles already.
So why wouldn't he fight in this battle with him?
This is the tension that David had been telling him the
whole time I've been fighting on your side
and now he's gonna be forced
to fight against his own people.
Like that's the tension we're in here.
That's the pickle David has created for himself is
that he'd been lying the whole time and now he's stuck.
He has to or tell the truth
and he could get killed for that.
He created this tension. He'd, he'd run into the wilderness.
He had run away from all the trust he supposedly had in God
and now he's created this mess of a situation.
And so like I said before, this is when the insertion
of Saul's story happens.
The narrator puts in the rest of chapter 28 as Saul
and his preparation for that battle.
What Saul doing at the same time, David's doing this, all of
that's leading us to chapter 31.
We'll come back to that next Sunday.
It's very revealing about Saul.
But again, we need to, we need to finish David's story here.
It creates tension about how they're both handling this.
We'll see it next week, but to finish David's story, we need
to see how this resolves.
So we need to skip ahead to chapter 29.
Watch David's story resolve here that,
that he had run into the wilderness.
Yes, that's part of it. He's running away from trust in God.
He's trying his own understanding.
Here's where we're at in the story,
but I've already mentioned Luke 15,
the parable of the prodigal son.
What we're gonna watch now is David
actually run back to his father.
David actually runs back to his father.
In the middle of the tension that he's in,
he runs back to his father.
And here's what's interesting about it.
The first move of this is actually by God himself.
It's not David waking up all
of a sudden realizing, well, I'm in trouble.
God, I need you. It was God who moved first, which he's done
that throughout the book, right?
He does that throughout history, is
that God providentially does works
to bring about His purposes in our lives.
It's God's initiative.
He's the one who works first and watch what he does here.
He providentially removed David from this tense situation
like David's in a no way out situation, no way out of this.
And God said, I got you. He removed David from it.
Here's how it went. Look at chapter
29 verses one through five.
Now, the Philistines had gathered all
their forces at a effect.
The Israelites were encamped by the spring.
That is in Jezreel, like the armies are amassing for battle.
It's coming here in a couple chapters.
Now, verse two, as the Lords
of the Philistines were passing on by hundreds
and by thousands marching kind
of preparation for the battle.
And David and his men were passing on in the rear with Aish,
the commanders of the Philistines said,
what are these Hebrews doing here?
Those are our enemies. Those are about,
we're we're about to fight them.
What are the Hebrews doing here?
And Aish said to the commanders of the Philistines,
is this not David, the servant of Saul, king of Israel,
who has been with me now for days and years
and since he deserted to me, I have found no fault in him
to this day, but the
commanders of the Philistines were angry with him.
And the commanders of the Philistines said to him,
send the man back that he may return
to the place to which you've assigned him.
He shall not go down to the battle with us,
lest in the battle he become an adversary to us.
For how could this fellow reconcile himself to his Lord?
Would it not be with the heads of the men here?
Meaning we, we know this guy.
He's probably plotting a military strategy here.
Don't let him. Verse five is this, not David
of whom they sing to one another in dances.
Saul struck down his thousands, David,
his 10 thousands, right?
Aish trusted David,
but the military commanders didn't 'cause they knew David.
They were on the battlefield with David.
They saw him strike down Goliath
and all these thousands of people.
They knew David, and they were like,
I don't trust him, but Aish did.
Why? Because David had been lying to him the whole time.
Look at how the tension builds.
Continuing in that vein, verse six, then Aish called David
and said to him, as the Lord, Yahweh lives,
you have been honest to me.
It seems right that you should march out
and end with me in the campaign
for I have found nothing wrong in you from the day
of your coming to me to this day.
Nevertheless, the Lords do not approve of you.
So go back, go peaceably
that you may not displease the Lords of the Philistines.
Now, watch this. David said to Aish, but what have I done?
What have you found in your servant from the day I entered
your service until now that I may not go
and fight against the enemies of my Lord the king.
David's just continuing to play it out in verse nine.
And Aish answered David
and said, I know that you are as blameless in my sight
as an angel of God.
Wow. Nevertheless, the commanders
of the Philistines have said,
he shall not go up with us to the battle.
Now again, the only reason Akos trusted David is
'cause David had been lying to him the whole time.
Yet, look at how God worked in spite of
that Verse 10,
Aish continued now then rise early in the morning
with the servants of your Lord who came with you.
Start early in the morning,
depart as soon as you have light.
And David set out with his men early in the morning
to return to the land of the Philistines to go home.
But the Philistines went up to Jezreel, to the battle.
Like, is that not great grace of God?
David ran away from trust.
David lied David try to manipulate.
And God said, I'm still going to remove you from
that situation so you don't have
to pay the consequence of it.
I mean, I dunno about you, but I, I can look back at my life
so many times that I've blown it.
I've run into some really tragic tense,
no way out situation.
And somehow God graciously removed me from it.
Not because I'm awesome or
because I was great to figure it out.
It's because he just graciously did it. And I was spared.
God did that for David here.
He looked like he might have to fight his own people.
He was in this mess. He deceived,
but God removed him from it completely.
God resolved the situation himself.
God opened the door for David to return to him.
Isn't God good like that?
But but before you get the wrong idea about this,
it wasn't then smooth sailing
from that point forward for David.
Like, oh, he got delivered. This is great.
He's gonna be all right. Everything's fine.
No, because while David
and his men were away preparing for this potential battle,
they have to be with Aish, they gotta march in the parade.
All these things, they're away from home.
While that happened, something terrible had occurred
continuing to chapter 30.
Now, when David and his men came
to Ziklag their hometown on the third day,
the Amalekites had made a raid against the nega,
against Ziklag.
They had overcome ziklag
and burned it with fire, had taken captive the women
and all who were in it, both small and great.
They killed no one, but carried them off and went their way.
And when David and his men came to the city,
they found it burned with fire and their wives and sons
and daughters taken captive.
Then David and the people who were
with him raised their voices
and wept until they had no more strength to weep.
David's two wives had also been taken captive, a em
of Jezreel and Abigail, the widow of Nal of Carmel.
And David was greatly distressed for the people spoke
of stoning him because all the people were bitter in soul
each for his sons and daughters.
What a terrible thing to come home to.
Right house burned down
wives, children, everybody's gone.
You don't know if they're dead or alive.
And it's just this tragedy.
I mean, you can think and imagine David
and his men would've been greatly distressed.
They would've been angry. Even the people were blaming
David, the one who got him into this mess.
Like, if we wouldn't have had to leave with Aish
and you weren't lying to him, then we would've not had
to leave our families here if we wouldn't have had
to leave Israel if you weren't afraid.
Like they're blaming David for every step of this. Terrible.
Now, I, I need to make a little bit of a sidebar here
for a second because I skipped something a couple weeks ago.
You might have picked it up. It, it's really something that
needs to be addressed because people will bring it up
as a question about the Bible
or a question about Christianity
and how it all works together.
It's the issue that we just saw
that David had multiple wives,
because that doesn't square with like what we all say.
Everything here is like, well, how, wait, wait a second.
David had, I thought he was a man after God's own heart.
He has multiple wives here. And it's not just David.
There are many instances of polygamy in the Old Testament.
So what do we do with that?
We can't just skate over it and say, ah, it's not important.
It, it's a big deal. What do we do with that?
Now, I'm gonna try to answer in a simple way.
It's not the full answer. You can do more research,
talk more about it later.
But here, here's, here's a brief way to understand this.
Remember first, that allowance is not the same as approval.
Just 'cause I've got allowed something
doesn't mean he approves of it.
And did he even allow it that?
We'll see that a little bit later, but,
but here's, here's some of the reasons maybe
that God allowed this is that many women couldn't provide
for themselves apart from prostitution
or slavery if they were by themselves on their own.
So this was a way to protect lives from tragedy like that.
It it was also, you go back to early days,
especially in history, when God says, be fruitful
and multiply and fill the earth.
It was a quicker way to do that actually.
And, and it wasn't mean.
It was always the right way,
but it was the way that it could have happened.
But, but in spite of all that, let me just be clear with
what we believe about now, how God sees it
as we move through the Bible.
It's very clear that monogamy one man
and one woman for life is conforming most closely
to God's ideal for marriage.
And just walk through the Bible.
Genesis two, before the fall
before sin into the world, the man was to leave his father
and mother and take his wife singular.
Even Deuteronomy 17, God commands the kings
before they even had kings.
He says, the kings must not take many wives
because it's gonna go real bad for them if they do.
Like I said, we're gonna see that in Second Samuel
with David himself.
And every other case it's
trouble in the New Testament.
One example, the qualifications
for leadership within the church, it says they are
to be a one woman man.
That's literally the phrase one woman man.
And if, if elders
and deacons in the church are to be examples morally,
then if that's the standard for a leader, then
everyone else called to follow that.
It should be the same, right?
One woman or, or one woman man
or one man, woman, you might say, right?
That's the picture. It paints Ephesians five.
Think about that. The beautiful picture of marriage that it,
it paints that it's a, an illustration of the gospel
between Christ and his church.
A husband and a wife are to illustrate that both practically
and spiritually of
how the gospel relationship with Christ works.
Then you go to revelation, Jesus comes back
for one bride, right?
That's the picture we collectively paint of the whole.
So while God seemed to allow it, we can't imitate it.
While God seemed to allow these things
to happen in the Old Testament, we can't imitate it
because his ideal is one man and one woman for life.
Anything else other than that causes heartache
and it does not honor God
or his design for how things are to work.
So that's the way we would stand on that truth.
But when we go back to one Samuel 30,
these men coming back from battle clearly cared about their
families, right?
They, they were not just flippant about the relationships,
they were distressed, they were hurt again.
They even wanted to kill David
for all this that had happened.
They were ready to take his life.
That's now the question, how is David gonna respond?
It seemed like he was removed from the tension first.
Now he's in a whole nother set of tension. What do I do now?
How does he respond? Look at the end of verse six.
But David strengthened
himself in the Lord his God.
He strengthened himself in all caps.
Lord Yahweh, the ever present, saving one who was also his
Elohim, saving Almighty God over all things.
That's who he strengthened himself in.
And that inner courage that he gained from
remembering his God again, that filling of his spirit again,
led him to then verse seven.
And David said to Abiathar, the priest, the son of a Alek,
bring me the eod.
So Abiathar brought the EOD to David.
That's what they used to inquire of God.
And David inquired of the Lord, shall I pursue
after this band of Amalekites?
Shall I overtake them? And God answered him, pursue
for you shall surely overtake and shall surely rescue.
So the contrast is that Saul had not done at all
recently anything like this of seeking the Lord.
David himself, even in chapter 27,
did not seek the Lord when he ran
away to the Philistine country.
Hear Finally we see it that David humbly
pursued God again.
He humbly sought the Lord, the pha, the priest.
That's how they did it. But he, he said, God,
I need you now.
I recognize I need you.
Look at David's transformation, right?
This is the prodigal son's story.
He trusted his own view of the situation he was in.
He led that, led him to run into the wilderness.
He looked at the stuff and
he said, I, I gotta get outta here.
Ran away. Now it is a new day.
He's finally trusting in the Lord.
Again, he's back to the David that we saw before.
He's back to the David who grew up trusting the Lord,
not leaning on his own understanding in all his ways,
acknowledging God, making his path straight.
That's what he now is back to.
Not only did God's presence fall on him again,
did God answer him?
God said, go.
And God in that going
provided providentially the victory for David
in this going, God said, I got you.
And here's victory.
I'm not gonna read chapter 30 as a whole.
I encourage you to go back and read it,
but it describes this providential victory.
See, David and his men took off.
They said, okay, we gotta chase
after the Amalekites, as they went through the desert.
They just happened upon a man in the middle
of the desert sitting there who was an Egyptian slave left
behind by the Amalekites.
They left him to die.
They just happened to, sorry, forget you we're outta here.
David and his men, they
don't know where the Amalekites went.
So they're running through the desert in the middle of this
huge expanse.
They happened to cross this man who knew exactly
where the Amalekites had gone, where they were going,
how they were getting there, all of that.
And this man leads David and his men to the Amalekite camp.
They crest the hill, they look down all their wives
and children, all their stuff is still there.
And they rejoice.
They go down, take out the Amalekites
and recover all their stuff.
It says nothing was lost. Isn't God good?
The tragedy they thought was happening, God
collected it all back.
This was the Lord's doing. We'll see David in a second.
Attribute it to God. It was the Lord's doing. First.
He provided the wisdom and courage to go.
David said, do I go? He said, yes, you're gonna win.
And then it also was that God
provided this man in the middle of the desert
who knew exactly where the enemy had gone.
All that happens. And then not only that,
they defeated the Amalekites, recovered everything.
Think about the party they would've thrown in relation
to God's grace to them, right?
They had it all. God led them.
They didn't, the the am Malachi didn't even have time
to do anything bad to the people that they had stolen.
God provided all right there. They didn't have to worry.
Think of the party when they get back home.
They got all their stuff back.
They got all their people back. Like, praise God.
It it, it reminds me of Luke 15,
the parable of the prodigal son.
When the father throws a huge party of celebration,
that his son who was dead is now alive again.
He's home. God says there's a party in heaven
for thought every time a sinner repents.
That's the kind of party you can imagine.
God's grace to them would've prompted.
And so David's heart is changing, right?
He's, he's conforming back to God's plan for him.
And we actually see one more glimpse of
that at the end of chapter 30.
See, David and his men returned with all their resources,
all the people, all those things.
But some of his men had stayed behind.
They were too exhausted to go into the battle.
They just stayed. And so as the, the rest
of the armies bringing the stuff
and people back with them, some of the men who had gone
to the battle were grumbling that man,
we shouldn't give those guys anything.
They didn't battle like we did. They stayed behind.
They were too tired, they're weak.
Give 'em their wives and children back.
But other than that, give them nothing.
The Bible refers to them as worthless fellows who said that.
But watch David his response,
verse 23 of chapter 30.
But David said, you shall not do so, my brothers, with
what the Lord has given us.
Again, we didn't earn this. We didn't gain. This is God.
He's preserved us, given into our hand.
The band that came against us who would listen
to you in this matter for as his share is
who goes down into the battle.
So shall hear his share be who stays by the baggage.
They shall share alike.
So David knew this was all Gods to begin with. What right?
Do I have to distribute it according to what I think?
Think no. I'm going to humbly obey the Lord in sharing it
with everybody who was a part of this.
Everybody in my camp, everybody gets an equal share.
He humbly obeyed God. Why did I say it that way?
Because that's what a king's supposed to do.
That's what a king God's command for a king was.
To be caring for his people, caring for his men,
caring for his families.
That's what a king was supposed to do.
Even sharing spoil with some of the people in Judah
that aren't even there.
He's like, Hey guys, I'm not against you.
He was using it to care for his brothers
and sisters even over there who are against him.
That's what a king is supposed to do.
David humbly obeyed God.
This is a picture of a man prepared for the throne.
All the tests, all the things
that God had brought him through.
He has finally been prepared to take the throne.
A very different picture than we'll see from Saul over the
next two weeks as David comes towards the throne.
Now, here's the question we've asked a number of times.
What do we do with all this ourselves?
I mean, that's a really cool story. It's fun.
Uh, I love that passage, but what do we do with it?
Well, I mentioned Luke 15, Jesus parable, the prodigal son.
It's similar because that parable,
if you read it later today
and you go study it, it creates some big questions
in our minds, in our hearts.
I think this does too. Some questions that we need to as,
as we look at David, how, how he initially responded to God,
how he initially responded to tense situations in his life.
As we reflect, consider our own reactions,
it raises some big questions.
And here's the first one that you can ask yourself,
that I can ask myself.
How am I leaning on my own understanding?
How am I leaning on my own understanding when I look
at the circumstances in front of me, in
I leaning on my own perceptions of that?
Or am I trusting the ever present
yet all powerful God and His path for me?
Which 1:00 AM I? Am I trusting myself or am I trusting God?
My limited view, my limited glimpse of everything I see?
Or am I trusting God's holistic,
eternal, infinite view of that?
Because watch, right?
Watch how essential Proverbs three, five
and six then becomes.
I know it's familiar, we put it on your notes,
but watch how essential this is.
Trust in the Lord with all your heart.
Do not lean on your own understanding in all your ways.
Acknowledge him and he will make straight your path.
Remember what happened when David trusted his own
understanding what happened?
Scared runs in the wilderness, creates an
seemingly impossible situation for himself.
He lived in fear and everyone suffered
around him because of it.
When he trusted his own, understand.
Yet, when he finally humbled himself to acknowledge
and seek the Lord,
what happened when he began really listening
to really trusting the Lord?
What happened? God straightened out his path,
brought victory, showed in the way, blessed him in grace.
So you need to answer, you need to answer that question.
You need to ask yourself,
where in my life am I leaning on my own understanding?
Am I seeing this situation from God's perspective or mine?
Am I responding to that person out
of a trust in the Lord, in a godly way?
Or am I responding to that person in a worldly way to try
to manipulate something that I can get out of it?
Am I living in fear that I'm going
to be single the rest of my life?
Or am I trusting God's good plan
for his glory through my life?
And we could keep going on
and on through all kinds of things,
but it's not just the big things.
It's the smallest things in our lives.
Am I trusting my own understanding
and how I use the money God's entrusted to me?
The time I have every day, my attitude, my focus?
Am I trusting my own understanding of how to live my life?
Or am I trusting his plan?
I think if we're honest, we would all say
that we're prone to wander.
We're prone to leave the God we say we love
his path, his straight way.
We're prone to wander all over the place.
That's why the second question is just as vital, how
do I need to then return to the Lord?
If my propensity is to wander?
How do I need to return to the Lord?
Like David finally did, right?
Like, like the prodigal son finally did.
After wasting his life in the wilderness,
wasting all the inheritance, he finally runs
back to his Father.
How do I need to return? Ask yourself And listen.
Maybe you have run down your path for a long time
and you have run that path headlong
as far away from your father,
as far away from God as you can.
And you've run that path as long and hard as you can,
and you've tried to fill your soul with empty things.
Is there any hope for you?
I would submit to you, yes there is,
because maybe you've run that path.
'cause you didn't know there was another one.
You didn't know that you could be near to your Father God,
you didn't know that you could know God.
And now all of a sudden you're awakening to this reality is
that you can know God.
You're seeing it for the first time.
You can have a relationship with the eternal God
of the universe and the, you know, you know how to do that.
The way you do that is you turn from your selfish way,
you turn from yourself and your sin,
and you turn to Jesus in his life, death
and resurrection for you.
And he says, you're mine now.
All through his love, in his death on the cross for you,
he says, your mine now and you're on his path.
But I know that probably more likely here is
that you are a son or daughter of God, yet you have felt
for years, months, weeks, whatever, this slow fade
drift into that wilderness
and you're exhausted and you are dry
and you're empty and you feel like every decision you're
making just keeps putting you deeper into the mess
and the tension of
life is there hope for you.
Trust in the Lord with all your heart.
Again, what that means is like as God enables you to do it,
you refocus regularly.
You draw near to him 'cause he's gonna draw near to you.
James says he's going to want you and you want him.
And it begins to trust him with all your heart, more
and more and more throughout your life.
Trust him with all your heart
and lean not on your own understanding.
Like stop listening to the lies of the world, of your flesh,
of the enemy humbly submit to say, God,
I don't have any clue what I'm doing.
I need you. I'm make a mess of it.
I cannot lean on my own understanding. I need yours.
I need yours through your word.
I need your understanding in all your ways. Acknowledge him.
That means sinner your life around His word,
his His lordship in your life, his love for you.
Everything around you is for him and through him.
And as you do all that, Proverbs three,
he will make straight your path drifts.
You're all over the place. Trust the Lord.
Don't lean your understanding, ignore your ways,
acknowledge him and he will straighten out your path.
So here's the question. Why don't you run home today?
Why don't you run home? Your father is waiting.
Your father is there.
His loving arms wide offering you
something that the wilderness
of this world can never offer you.
He's offering it to you if you would just run home.
So run home today, friend, wherever you have been,
whatever you have done, run home to him today.
In fact, the the Lord's Supper actually is a means
for us to do that.
And so I'm gonna invite Aaron, one of our elders up here
to walk us through this, but,
but use this time
to run home, whatever way that means for you.
Run home to him today.